so i hate to tell you this but it seems  like the trump campaign might not have  been  on the level thousands are claiming that  they were scammed out of millions of  dollars because  they went to donate to the trump  campaign but instead of the trump  campaign taking only one donation  it actually took a series of recurring  donations and  looking at the language you can see why  someone would be confused that  if you didn't uncheck a box that was  already checked  it would lead to more recurring or at  least multiple donations and the part  that says that there is a recurring  transaction is actually smaller than the  rest of the text  many are claiming that this is an unfair  business practice and that they were  scamming people out of money and it's no  surprise that  many thousands of people were able to  get refunds as a result  of these practices we'll see if this  leads to more inquiries than just that  and we'll see you  in court